on va parler de ces nuits successives et
pas seulement dans les grandes villes et
les bons lieux les petites villes sont
aussi touchées comment expliquer cette
situation et comment y répondre et
va-t-on vers un retour au calme alors
que la nuit qui vient de s'écouler
semble avoir été plus calme que les
précédentes et puis l'attitude de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la France
insoumise et vivement critiqué par
l'exécutif par la droite par le
rassemblement national à leur a-t-il une
part de responsabilité dans la situation
de pays qu'on ne dirait évidemment ce
que vous en pensez d'abord on va aller
voir comment s'est passé la nuit du côté
de Marseille
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
donc à Marseille retrouver les hauts
purgate bonjour Léo merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous président et directeur
éditorial de la Marseillaise Marseille
qui a connu des nuages JT cette semaine
comment s'est passé cette nuit
mais cette nuit a été a été beaucoup
plus calme que les deux précédentes ou
effectivement Marseille avait connu des
émeutes des violences des pillages des
incendies ce qui n'avait pas été le cas
en 2005
cette nuit a été beaucoup plus calme je
vous le disais il y a eu 21
interpellations d'après la préfecture de
police des Bouches-du-Rhône et nous
avons eu des tentatives des fractions de
quelques tabacs mais sans commune mesure
avec les violences et les pillages qui
avaient secoué la ville les deux nuits
précédentes
Léo vous l'avez dit il y a eu des dégâts
à Marseille avec ses nuages agités hier
le maire de Marseille Benoît Payan a
pris la parole il a annoncé des aides
absolument le maire de Marseille a
indiqué qu'il allait mobiliser des fonds
pour venir en aide aux commerçants
notamment du centre-ville mais certains
en périphérie ont été également touchés
cet argent va se conjuguer avec les
initiatives qui vont être prises dès ce
matin et annoncer à l'Hôtel de Région
par Renault museliers le président de
région et Martine vassal la présidente
du conseil départemental et de la
métropole l'ensemble des collectivités
et bien se mobilisent à la fois pour
venir en aide à ces commerçants dont les
boutiques ont été saccagées mais aussi
leur permettre de rouvrir le plus tôt
possible et notamment pour reprendre le
cours des soldes
merci Léo on suivra évidemment ce qui se
passe du côté de Marseille on regarde la
Une de La Marseillaise justement sur la
lourde facture de la terrible fracture
sociale c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Léo d'avoir été avec nous
Catherine la nuit semble avoir semble
avoir été plus calme même si on a appris
à l'instant le dessert d'un jeune
pompier qui luttait contre des feux
est-ce que c'est un retour au calme qui
marque la fin de ses émeutes où est-ce
qu'on est dans un retour au calme
temporaire je peux pas vous le dire je
pense que personne ne peut vraiment le
dire ce qu'on peut dire c'est que on
voit qu'on est dans une société qui est
vraiment extrêmement
éruptive sous tension et que une on peut
penser que les choses se rentrent dans
le calme et hop ça repart par ailleurs
on avait un peu la fin du mouvement des
retraites et c'est reparti de cette
manière donc est-ce que c'est la fin de
cette séquence là c'est possible est-ce
qu'il y en aura d'autres c'est aussi
possible
cet été peut être tendu aussi avec les
difficultés qui sont liées au
réchauffement climatique comme on a vu
l'année dernière donc franchement je
pense qu'on peut pas se le dire par
contre ce qu'on peut prévoir c'est que
on n'a pas de ressort on a une société
qui n'a pas de capacité à absorber les
chocs et que d'un seul coup ça hop ça
repart sans arriver à pouvoir les les
régler les gérer les absorber on est une
société sous tension complète et on va
en parler évidemment mais sur les deux
nuits qui viennent de s'écouler qui sont
plus calmes que les précédentes
l'exécutif a déployé 45000 policiers
gendarmes à chaque fois finalement
l'état d'urgence n'a pas été déclenché
est-ce que ça a été bien géré par
l'exécutif je pense que on a pu éviter
l'état d'urgence je pense c'était
vraiment le signal le pire qui aurait pu
être envoyé que de faire l'état
d'urgence je crois pas je pense que
évidemment le déploiement policier a
compté je pense pas que ce soit la seule
explication je pense qu'on était
vraiment dans une réaction extrêmement
forte extrêmement puissante devant
quelque chose qui a choqué la France
entière hein qui a choqué les jeunes des
cités mais pas seulement et ils ont
réagi de manière
comment dire dans un endroit où il y a
pas beaucoup de structuration politique
donc c'est parti un peu dans tous les
sens et dans ce temps tous les sens il y
a eu un peu de tout qui s'est mêlé mais
le point de départ c'était quand même
une immense scolaire un effroi devant la
vie le sentiment que bah ça ne se règle
pas le problème de leur insertion dans
la société ne se fait pas les inégalités
persistent et toi là ils l'ont exprimé
comme ça alors dessus ce sont greffés
des tas de choses parasites mais le fond
de l'affaire c'est que il y a quelque
chose qui est enquisté dans notre
société et dans les banlieues et dans le
rapport des jeunes avec la police et
dans les pratiques policières est-ce
qu'il y a d'une forme de soulagement du
côté de l'exécutif de voir que le calme
revient dans le pays parce que le
problème est beaucoup plus profond que
ça et il va falloir le régler je vais
pas être dans le commentaire quand le
calme est relatif et je veux adresser
tout mon soutien à la famille de ce
pompier et toutes mes pensées assez
collègues et toutes les condoléances au
nom du parti Renaissance à ce
sapeur-pompier qui n'avait que 24 ans et
donc je ne crois pas qu'on puisse déjà
parler d'un retour au calme dans cette
situation qui reste évidemment à
préciser évidemment par le ministre de
l'Intérieur
ensuite ce qui est certain c'est que le
Président de la République et le
gouvernement ont tout mis très
rapidement sur la table comme option
comme solution pour éviter
l'état d'urgence pour éviter de recourir
à des états d'exception et
l'intervention nombreuse des forces de
l'ordre asse semble-t-il été utiles
notamment depuis le début du week-end
par la suite il faudra trouver des
solutions politiques c'est le sens de
l'invitation aujourd'hui à l'Élysée que
Gérard Larcher et de Yaël Brown Pivet
des mers qui seront reçus demain par le
Président de la République des maires
qui sont évidemment toujours au centre
de la décision politique en ce qui
concerne leur commune et
particulièrement ces quartiers
prioritaires de la ville un chiffre
simplement quand j'entendais que les
inégalités persistent bien sûr qu'il y a
des inégalités le taux de chômage dans
les qpv les quartiers priorités de la
ville et passer de 23% ce qui est énorme
ce qui est bien trop évidemment en 2017
à l'arrivée au pouvoir d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui il est à 18%. c'est toujours
trop mais ces cinq points de moins il y
a des efforts qui ont été faits pour ces
quartiers prioritaires de la ville mais
lorsque je vois ces derniers jours des
maisons France services parfois inauguré
la semaine d'avant c'est le cacher robar
Redal député Renaissance à Juvisy dans
l'Essonne quand je vois la salle de boxe
d'une association depuis 40 ans qui
aidait justement à l'insertion des
jeunes qui a été brûlé quand je vois des
commerces qui sont parfois installés
dans ces une prioritaire de la ville
saccagées pillées moi je ne vois pas de
l'inégalité je vois de la violence je
vois du saccage gratuit et c'est contre
ça qu'il faut lutter avant de lutter
contre les inégalités luttons contre la
violence retour à l'ordre républicain et
ça je ne l'ai pas entendu madame tricot
dont la bouche dans les propos d'une
certaine gauche que vous représentez
parfois à travers votre revue et je
pense ici à la France insoumise nous
sommes aussi dans une situation et vous
faisiez un parallé à l’intéressant avec
la contestation sur la réforme des
retraites ou jamais il n'y a eu d'appel
au calme et plutôt de la surenchère de
la part de la France insoumise qui pour
moi je vous le dis très clairement ces
derniers jours est sorti de l'arc
républicain moi ce que je pensais que ce
que la vision que vous avez de du pays
ne correspond pas à ce que les gens
vivent et je pense ça participe à
l'attention c'est-à-dire quand vous nous
dites que certes ça ne va pas bien mais
que ça s'améliore je crois que
véritablement vous ne vous ne vous
rendez pas compte à quel point les gens
souffrent et vivent quelque chose qui se
dégrade vous venez de prendre de
chiffres du chômage
18%, vous avez fait baisser le chômage
notamment par le développement des
petits boulots qui sont par exemple
chauffeur uber c'est à dire sont des
métiers
vous me laissez parler s'il vous plaît
voilà ce que je vous dis c'est que ce ne
sont pas des enfants en fait et il
commence il commence à se confronter à
la réalité on connaît tellement votre
discours qu'il commence à se confronter
à la réalité il a compris j'entendais
Luc car vous n'ajuste avant dire
attention attention à gauche est-ce que
la gauche est en train de se confronter
au réel et la gauche est en train de
comprendre que son discours est parfois
et moi de nature à rendre violent les
individus qu'elle pense traiter
électoralement et autrement elle ne sert
pas à les sortir et les insérer dans la
société voilà je pense que vous ne
rendez pas compte du réel c'est à dire
que je pense que vous ne prenez pas la
mesure à la fois la souffrance oui
absolument vous ne prenez pas prenez pas
compte rendez pas compte de la mesure
prenez pas la mesure de la souffrance
qu'il y a dans ces quartiers qui est lié
au fait que
les parcours scolaires sont extrêmement
contraints que le les parcours
professionnels sont très difficiles
parce que vous habitez là parce que vous
avez ce nom là que les relations avec la
police sont exécrables que les
conditions de logements sont très
difficiles c'est de cela dont vous ne
rendez pas compte et comme vous racontez
une histoire qui est inverse à celle-là
c'est que ça s'améliore alors que ce
n'est pas ce que les gens vivent vous
les mettez dans une situation de tension
vous n'avez pas il se trouve qu'il
reçoit sur les réseaux sociaux et
ressorti la déclaration de Jacques
Chirac en 2005 au moment des émeuts de
2005 Jacques Chirac avait cherché des
mots d'apaisement et de compréhension
vous n'en faites aucun vous n'êtes pas
allé voir cette maman la maman de Naël
aime n'a pas eu la visite du chef de
l'État ou de la première ministre vous
ne faites pas de mode d'apaisement de
compréhension
depuis la mort de Delhaize comment vous
parlez vous vous rendez que vous êtes
toujours dans l'affrontement que vous
êtes toujours dans la critique quand
vous toujours dans des constats qui date
parfois dit à 20 ans vous parlez de
Jacques Chirac qui a ressortir sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Emmanuel Bompard qui ont
ressorti cette vidéo pour encore une
fois sortir de la cohésion nationale et
essayer d'enfoncer un coin dans la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron vous êtes
dans une haine systématique du président
de la République vous êtes dans la
détestation profonde de l'action et de
la personne du président de la
République depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
en 2017 pardon si c'est difficile pour
vous moi j'essaye dénoncer des faits et
vous êtes toujours dans la constatation
et dans la contestation et dans
l'opposition systématique à ce que nous
faisons est-ce que j'ai dit que dans les
quartiers tout va bien non j'ai dit que
par rapport aux inégalités que vous
décrivez comme croissante je vous donne
une chose un chiffre et vous l'expliquez
évidemment par des baguettes magiques ou
des tours de passe-passe ce n'est pas le
cas quand on passe de 23% 18% de chômage
cela veut dire que les inégalités
réduisent et qu'on sort et qu'on sort de
la précarité ça ne vous plaît pas
chauffeur uber peut-être moi aussi je
préférerais que tout le monde ait un
métier qui paye mieux et qui paye
davantage et dans des conditions de
travail exemplaires mais je préfère
chauffeur uber que au chômage je vous
donne un exemple très simple j'habite la
Seine-Saint-Denis les enfants sont
scolarisés en Seine-Saint-Denis
excusez-moi un beau lieu toute ma vie
donc non
la Seine-Saint-Denis un enfant qui est
scolarisé en Seine-Saint-Denis perd une
année de scolarité sur la période de sa
scolarisation faute de professeur
remplacée c'est à dire que ça c'est une
inégalité mais énorme les gens dans les
quartiers populaires par exemple n'ont
pas de médecins enfin je veux dire c'est
il faut se rendre compte du niveau de
dégradation et des services publics et
des Services que tout un chacun peut
avoir et qui sont eux ils savent que à
côté c'est possible mais que chez eux ce
n'est pas le cas ce que je veux dire
c'est que cette inégalité qui est
visible qui ressenti ce que c'est
uniquement dans les quartiers Catherine
tricot parce que
je veux dire c'est que dans les
quartiers
la dégradation des services publics elle
est générale je suis tout à fait
d'accord dans les quartiers populaires
elle est aggravée notamment parce qu'ils
sont retirés ou alors qu'ils sont
dégradés comme je viens de dire pour ce
qui concerne l'école puisque vous avez
un an de particularisation en moins pour
les enfants de la Seine-Saint-Denis je
regrette mais c'est quelque chose de
inimaginable le rapport Borlo avait
montré en 2018 que dans les quartiers
populaires on investit moins les
habitants des quartiers populaires
reçoivent moins d'aide de plus les
services publics par exemple que les
habitants
ont un en France c'est-à-dire que les
quartiers populaires ne reçoivent pas
plus mais reçoivent moins que la moyenne
nationale je veux dire on est il faut
quand même se rendre compte que et tout
le monde le sait l'autre jour je lisais
un atome de Monsieur Rio le maire de
Grigny qui dit par exemple que dans les
cités populaires maintenant les anciens
ne peuvent plus partir donc il reste
dans leur logement mais les retraites
sont si faibles si petites que c'est pas
eux qui payent leur loyer ce sont leurs
enfants donc tout ça ça résonne avec ce
qui vient de se passer sur la réforme
des retraites c'est à dire que les
retraites sont plus petites les départs
sont plus les gens sont en souffrance
ils passent au RSA avant passer à la
retraite et c'est les enfants qui payent
les loyers uniquement imputables à
Emmanuel Macron ou est-ce que c'est le
résultat de 40 ans d'échecs de la
politique de la ville non pas de
politique de la ville non non ça je suis
pas d'accord je suis architecte et
urbaniste donc je peux dire que la
politique de la ville on a vraiment fait
des choses par contre ce que je pense
c'est que on ne peut pas régler cette
situation uniquement à coup de
reconstruction de rénovation urbaine
c'est le problème il est bien plus grave
la question des services publics ce
n'est pas la question de la politique de
la ville la question du de l'emploi ce
la vie donc la politique de la ville
elle a fait elle a fait beaucoup elle ne
peut pas tout elle doit compter elle a
bien fait
pas toujours pas toujours je trouve
qu'on a souvent par exemple été assez
brutal aussi dans la boutique de la
ville on a démoli brutalement des
milliers et des milliers de logements
mais disons qu'elle a fait on peut au
moins on peut se dire qu'il y a eu des
efforts qui ont été des milliards qui
ont été mis sur la table et notamment
après 2005 c'est l'effet de 2005 quand
on pense que il ne se gagne rien de se
faire rien non là il s'est fait quelque
chose mais ce qui s'est fait n'a pas
résolu la question sur le fond et sur le
fond je vous dis c'est que véritablement
on a un problème de d'égalité dans les
territoires d'égalité sociale et on a un
problème qui vient de enfin je veux dire
qui se voit avec à l'affiche qu'on a un
problème avec notre police on a un
problème de la relation entre la police
et les citoyens et on a un problème on a
vous ne pouvez pas me laisser dire ça
mais je vais quand même terminer ma
phrase on a un problème de relation de
la police avec les citoyens on a un
problème de théorie de théorie de
théorie du maintien de l'ordre et on a
un problème avec les syndicats de police
qui maintenant se mettent à menacer le
pouvoir en place de ne plus les soutenir
ça qu'il se comporte comme des factieux
on est très on ne trouve très urgent de
dissoudre les militants et les
associations de militants écologistes
par contre là je pense qu'on devrait
s'intéresser véritablement à ce qui est
en train de se passer avec la police qui
menace directement explicitement le
pouvoir et on va laisser m'écrire déjà
sur votre comparaison avec les
associations écologistes vous aurez
remarqué que Gérald Darmanin a engagé
une procédure de dissolution pour un de
ces syndicats non représentatifs la
semaine dernière
je vous parle je vous parle 49% qui
a formé
et son n'est plus faire de l'action
syndicale mais de faire la guerre je
vous parle de ce café le ministre de
l'Intérieur il parle des habitants des
quartiers comme des nuisibles je vous
parle de ce qu'a fait le ministre de
l'Intérieur
non représentatif qui a engagé une
procédure de dissolution à son rencontre
la semaine dernière en revanche quand
vous dites que certains policiers je
crois sont factieux quand je crois que
vous donc j'aime pas je crois vous dites
que des policiers sont mais
pardonnez-moi mais regardez ces images
se sont des enfants de la République
aussi je vois bien que vous choisissez
vos combats mais pardon mais la police
protège la police mais vous savez bien
qu'elle protège pas toujours mais non
mais n'a pas poussé moi c'est pas la
police c'est un policier cher madame et
l'enquête dira ce qui s'est passé
la police ne tue pas
lorsqu'il s'est passé un policier a tué
et je ne me permettrai pas de commenter
le moindre fait en ce qui concerne ce
qui s'est passé à Nanterre d'accord
contrairement à vous je ne remets pas en
cause ni la police ni la justice j'ai
confiance dans la justice de mon pays et
je crois et je suis sincèrement et je
suis j'ai de l'amour donc j'attends
beaucoup j'attends qu'une autre devienne
monopole de l'amour ni de quoi que ce
soit simplement simplement
madame la police est républicaine votre
camp politique que vous faites semblant
d'ailleurs ok de ne pas appartenir parce
que vous êtes journaliste je crois mais
vous défendez exactement très portrait
les
positions de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la
France insoumise la France insoumise est
en train de fissurer l'arc républicain
est en train de sortir de l'arc
républicain quand justement elle dit que
la police ne protège pas quand elle dit
que la justice n'est pas forcément
impartial quand elle dit que la police
tue ça je crois qu'on sort de l'arc
republicain et surtout quand la France
insoumise n'appelle pas au calme vue sur
un point de vue c'est pas un point de
vue c'est pas la pratique politique mais
attendez pardon on sort pas de l'arc
républicain quand on a un poids quand on
a un produit du gouvernement ou sur la
police
que les policiers sont factieux on sort
pas de la républicain non on a le droit
de le dire non mais moi je trouve qu'on
a en République ce que vous voulez il y
a la liberté d'expression mais tout
simplement je trouve que c'est grave de
prendre de telles positions est-ce que
vous dites pour vous protéger madame
je trouve ça incroyable dans la
situation dans laquelle on est quand
encore une fois il y a trois policiers
qui ont été blessés hier soir quand on a
45000 jeunes pour la plupart parce que
ce sont des jeunes pour la plupart qui
viennent vous protéger qui viennent
protéger le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses qui
viennent protéger des familles qui ont
été attaquées parfois avec des bébés de
19 mois dans des voitures à coup de jets
de pavés vous trouvez ça normal pas moi
moi je trouve que la police est dans son
rôle et de la police parfois peu et
dépolliciers parfois peuvent agir de
manière malheureuse condamnable et ça
c'est à la justice de le dire à chaque
fois que ce sera le cas vous n'avez pas
de penser vous n'en avez jamais dès
qu'il s'agit d'un policier qui qui
trouve ça condamnable les propos qui
sont les sources
parce que je pense qu'il y a des
pratiques racistes qui sont devenues
endémiques à l'intérieur de la police ça
fait plusieurs fois que l'ONU nous
accroche sur ce sujet que l'Europe nous
accroche sur ce sujet il y a un rapport
qui est sorti il y a trois jours qui dit
la France doit regarder de façon claire
et lucide des problèmes de racisme
systémique à l'intérieur
qui a nommé évidemment par des pays qui
ne soutiennent pas la France donc ça
s'appelle non mais journaliste c'est pas
l'ONU
pour moi je pense qu'il y a un problème
de racisme qui est devenu endémique et
systémique au sens où on ne le combat
pas au sens où à l'intérieur du corps
d'avoir le corps de la police est très
mal formé très peu formé ils ont un an
de formation quand en Allemagne on en a
trois ils ont des une rapport à la
violence et notamment à l'usage des
armes qui s'est développée de manière
absolument débridée et on le voit depuis
2016 avec les lois de travail les gilets
jaunes la réforme des retraites
c'est pas mes obsessions c'est quand
même c'est
les Français l'ont vu les Français les
Français les Français l'ont vu
massivement ont vu massivement que on a
un usage de la police qui est un usage
de maintien de massivement la police
mais moi aussi je soutiens la police
vous soutenez la police des armées je
soutiens les gardiens de la paix
voyez-vous
les gardiens de la paix sont des gens
qui maintiennent l'ordre vous êtes dans
le camp des factieux pardonnez-moi
à dire ça
c'est terrible d'entendre ça non mes
cheveux
Catherine tricot terminé terminé votre
argumentation ce que je dis c'est qu'il
y a marginal un problème
très difficile sur la question du
racisme sur l'usage disproportionné de
de la violence pour le maintien de
l'ordre que cette repérer maintenant à
l'échelle internationale et que ça pose
un problème qu'on ne résoudra pas si
avec dans les relations avec les
habitants des quartiers avec les
syndicalistes avec le mouvement social
sont des questions profondes qui
auxquelles il faut s'attaquer et que on
peut faire des moulinets avec les bras
ça ne change rien à la réalité cette
image moi c'est de voir des robocops
comme ça en permanence je vous assure
que ça devient difficile d'aller en
manifestation les gens ont peur d'aller
en manifestation parce qu'ils ont peur
d'être gazés d'être Nasser de façon
totalement intempestive sans avoir vu
venir par sans voir partir le coup d'un
seul coup vous êtes en manifestation il
y a une enfin moi je l'ai fait avec mon
papa qui a 85 ans je peux vous dire que
c'est quand même assez compliqué de se
retrouver dans une manifestation quand
on est gazé quand on avait qu'un vieux
monsieur qui manifeste tranquillement un
mode réponse avec Seigneur après on vous
écoute je vais pas m'étendre parce que
je crois que j'ai dit le fond de ma
pensée simplement l'extrême gauche et
cette gauche que représente madame
tricot la France insoumise l'extrême
gauche vous êtes d'extrême gauche et en
tout cas vous représentez les idées de
l'extrême gauche sur le plan politique
et notamment celle de la France
insoumise et pour moi
cette extrême gauche est en train de
faire le lit du rassemblement national
et le marche-pied de Marine Le Pen et
vous êtes tous collectivement dans le
rang de la France insoumise et ceux qui
les soutiennent les idiots utiles de
Marine Le Pen et ça je pense que c'est
très clair dans l'esprit des Français
aujourd'hui on va écouter quelques
réactions politiques sur la position de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vis-à-vis de ses
émotic qui est très critiqué ces
derniers jours Alex le leader de la
France insoumise au début des émeutes
estimé que son rôle n'était pas
d'appeler au calme mais à la justice et
à la vérité il a dénoncé à la
responsabilité du pouvoir politique dans
la situation de ces quartiers populaires
et également celle de la police dans la
violence de ces jeunes et cette analyse
est bien elle est pointée du doigt par
une grande partie de la classe politique
et notamment à droite et au
rassemblement national le patron du RN
Jordan Bardella estime que LFI est
devenue je cite la France incendiaire on
va l'écouter que Mélenchon si vous
voulez c'est le rebelle mais depuis son
salon c'est Monsieur Mélenchon il doit
être dans son appartement parisien il
doit inciter à la rébellion très très
loin des beaux quartiers et je peux vous
dire que ça doit faire très longtemps
que Monsieur Mélenchon a pas vécu dans
une cité HLM aux élus si tentait qu'il y
ait déjà était confronté que Mélenchon
est un danger public et qu'il devrait se
rappeler que dans le mot responsables
politiques il y a responsable du côté
des républicains Richie le patron du
parti LR par le même de poursuites
judiciaire vis-à-vis de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Monsieur Mélenchon est un
danger pour la République Monsieur
Mélenchon est un factieux les insoumis
sont des dangers pour la République ces
discours ils ont des conséquences on a
tiré sur des policiers avec de la
chevrotine à Vaulx-en-Velin trois
policiers ont été blessés sérieusement
on a poignardé je le redis à Marseille
des policiers en civils tout ça a des
conséquences tout ça a des conséquences
et on eux il faudra que des magistrats
apprécient ceux qui ont allumé les
mèches de tout cela aussi compris
Jean-Luc Mélenchon
de la France insoumise a souhaité
répondre c'était hier chez nos confrères
de LCI
monsieur Ciotti je le connais je l'ai
fréquenté il ne m'a jamais parlé comme
ça qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire je suis un danger pour la
République est-ce qu'il ne croit pas que
le danger pour la République c'est
plutôt quand une force armée prétend
qu'elle fait la guerre au peuple ça oui
c'est en danger pour la République donc
si j'ai bien compris il y a un problème
dans tous les quartiers de ce pays 45
000 hommes n'y ont pas mis un terme les
plus prestigieux n'ont pas été entendus
mais c'est la faute premièrement de la
France insoumise pardon je change leurs
deux Jean-Luc Mélenchon de la France
insoumise des parents et des jeux vidéo
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est une
attitude sérieuse voilà en précise aussi
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon il suit à des
critiques également à gauche de la part
des socialistes et des écologistes
est-ce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est sorti
de l'arc Républic comme l'a dit donc
évidemment pas je pense que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon exprime et il est un des rares
à exprimer ce que ressentent les gens
des quartiers populaires où il nous a
pas échappé que Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
recueilli
près de 40% des voix dans les quartiers
populaires c'est à dire que sa voix qui
s'est élevée contre le discours de haine
d'Éric Zemmour qui aujourd'hui prend en
charge la question de des inégalités de
la question des violences que subissent
les jeunes notamment avec des contrôles
offaces qui sont systématiques des fois
c'est 10 15 fois par jour que déjà dans
les quartiers sont confrontés aux
policiers qui leur demandent et kirikan
et qui reviennent leur rendement
c'est-à-dire qu'on a dû harcèlement dans
les quartiers populaires Jean-Luc
Mélenchon parle de ça et je vais vous
dire une chose je pense que dans la
difficulté dans laquelle on se trouve
c'est que dans les quartiers populaires
il n'y a plus de structuration politique
il y a plus d'associations qui tiennent
vraiment debout ce qui reste c'est
encore des élus locaux et je pense que
le fait que Jean-Luc Mélenchon soit
celui qui se met du côté de ces jeunes
là en essayant de mettre des mots sur ce
qui se sur ce qu'il ressentent et
éventuellement de proposer une sortie
j'ai entendu hier ce qu'il a fait une
disposition que moi j'espérais c'est à
dire que il y ait une rassemblement de
toutes les forces de gauche des
syndicats des associations des partis
politiques pour dire qu'on veut une
autre police et qu'on pour dire qu'on
veut une politique de justice sociale je
pense que le fait que possible parce que
Alex le disait à gauche il est critiques
et c'est le fait d'avoir dit la police
suisse ça passe pas c'est possible que
ça à gauche oui c'est possible néanmoins
l'ensemble de la gauche il l'avait dit
avant les élections il avait dit avant
la création de la nups et ça n'a pas
empêché la nupette qui est des
désaccords d'appréciation c'est possible
néanmoins ce que je pensais que
l'essentiel de la gauche et c'est ça qui
change d'ailleurs par rapport à 2005
c'est que la gauche a pris la mesure de
la difficulté dans lesquelles se
trouvent les jeunes des quartiers et les
quartiers d'une façon générale Jean-Luc
Mélenchon met des mots là-dessus et
c'est la condition pour pouvoir revenir
dans un rapport politique et donc
finalement dans une résolution
démocratique du conflit et John et je
regrette qu'il soit actuellement trop
seul à exprimer cette situation
tout a été dit 40% de ces quartiers ont
voté en faveur de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
donc Jean-Luc Mélenchon contre vents et
marais essaye de cajoler cet électoral
là quitte à dire strictement
méthodiquement n'importe quoi et quitte
à sortir encore une fois par ses propos
de l'arc républicain c'est ce qui est en
train d'être fait à la France insoumise
et ce qui est en train d'être perçu par
ses alliés écologistes et socialiste et
donc on assiste à quoi à la fracturation
de l'alliance des contraires de cette
alliance électoraliste populiste de
laupes et tant mieux que ça se clarifie
ça se clarifie déjà ces dernières
semaines en vue des élections
européennes personne n'est d'accord mais
aujourd'hui surtout personne n'est
d'accord avec l'instigateur de cette
nupaise Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui reste
dans son camp seul isolé factieux contre
la police et contre l'autorité et contre
la République Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a
qu'un seul rêve l'accession de pouvoir
de Marine Le Pen pour mieux la contester
et pouvoir faire tomber les institutions
c'est le projet politique que porte la
France insoumise et que porte Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui-même d'ailleurs vous avez
vu sur ses doigts il ne supporte pas
être derrière son camp mais d'abord
Jean-Luc Mélenchon toujours d'abord
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais ce qu'il risque
Jean-Luc Mélenchon aujourd'hui c'est la
détestation de son propre camp tant il
va tant il va j'ai entendu Luc car vous
naze et j'ai bien écouté ce que disait
lucarbonate la nuit pèse c'est un
colosse au pied d'argile aujourd'hui
elle est fragilisée par celui qui l'a
monté qu'il l'a inventé qu'il l'a créé
mais de toute pièce parce que c'est
l'alliance des contraires qui n'avait à
l'époque qu'une ambition électoraliste
et les Français se rendent bien compte
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et dans le camp
des factieux est en train de sortir de
la républicain et que la France
insoumise en appelant pas au calme en ne
respectant pas la justice et en appelant
pas les banlieues justement à rester
soudés dans la République porte une
grave responsabilité voire une
complicité dans ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours et nous le disons très
clairement en train de se rendre je
pense que la gauche est unie parce que
pendant son électorat de demande parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui nous
unissent à la fois dans les valeurs et
dans les combats je crois que la nuit
pêche a besoin certainement de se
rééquilibrer de se refonder et de
travailler pour approfondir ces accords
et non pas ne pas en rester à un accord
qui s'est lié au moment des élections
législatives donc je crois qu'il y a des
problèmes à gauche cependant ce que je
pense c'est que sur le fond nous avons
beaucoup de choses en commun et en
particulier le goût de la République le
goût de l'égalité et que en ce moment
nous sommes du côté de de ceux qui
cherchent à une sortie à cette situation
qui ne soit pas qu'une sortie je dirais
à coup de 45000 policiers dans la dans
la rue merci
pour ce débat on va continuer évidemment
à parler de ces émeutes ça fait la une
de la presse régionale
[Musique]
de la presse régionale c'est
l'indignation après l'attaque du
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
effectivement c'est l'attaque de trop
titre Le Télégramme gravissime pour le
journal Nice-Matin intolérable pour midi
libre ça suffit c'est le cri d'alarme du
titre de la Provence aujourd'hui on le
rappelle le domicile du maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses dans le Val-de-Marne a
été attaqué à la voiture bélier dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche alors qu'il y
avait à l'intérieur ces enfants de 5 et
7 ans et son épouse son épouse qui a
réussi à s'enfuir avec ses enfants mais
qui sait fracturé le tibia mer et
citoyen sont invités à se rassembler
aujourd'hui à midi sur le parvis des
mairies en solidarité avec le maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses également de toutes les
victimes de ses émeutes 150 mairies ou
bâtiments municipaux ont été attaqués
depuis mardi la Marseillaise se penche
sur ses commerçants en détresse qui ont
vu leurs établissements attaquer et oui
la facture de ses émeutes est lourde
pour les commerçants après les scènes de
pillage aussi inédites que violente la
facture dans la région Aix-Marseille
s'élève pour l'instant à 100 millions
d'euros et un fonds de soutien va être
créé par les collectivités et le monde
économique et Alex dans le Nord un
collectif d'habitants des quartiers
contre les quartiers effectivement j'ai
dans mon lancement contre voilà un
collectif d'habitants dans les quartiers
qui est bien fait des marches contre les
violences s'étaler une de nos éclair
voilà c'est à Lille les quartiers du
Nord de la métropole ont été touchés par
les émeutes et des collectifs
d'habitants s'organisent des pères des
mères des frères et sœurs qui d'abord se
mobilisent sur les réseaux sociaux et
font par exemple des marches de nuit
pour parler aux jeunes à proposer une
oreille attentive notamment sur
l'injustice que représente la mort du
jeune Naël il y a également du
porte-à-porte qui est réalisé dans les
immeubles pour sensibiliser les parents
notamment sur l'importance de tenir
certains jeunes qui participeraient à
ses émeutes et puis c'est parents et ses
membres des familles veulent aussi
occuper le terrain dans les cités le
terrain des jeunes et à Reims ce sont
les chefs de communauté religieuses qui
appellent effectivement les
représentants des trois principales
communautés religieuses font des marches
également dans le quartier de la
Croix-Rouge pour appeler au calme je
vais citer et bien l'imam de la grande
mosquée de Reims Omar Bendaoud nous ne
sommes pas là pour donner des leçons
mais semer des graines d'apaisement et
comme en 2005 à chaque événement grave
nous nous rassemblons pour montrer que
nous sommes unis merci Alex
sommeil c'était un une qui date un tout
petit peu parce qu'elle était faite au
monde des 100 jours on voyait qu'il
attendait que le temps passe donc voilà
il y aura une nouvelle lune au mois de
juillet
d'avoir été avec nous merci Alex si vous
voulez voir revoir cette émission c'est
sur public c'est la.fr prochain
rendez-vous à 18h Thomas hugs France
public et puis à 19h30 Elisabeth
martichou reçoit marine tondeuillier
dans audition publique très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]